you said you were open about porn what
what type of porn are you watching are
you watching me
what is your thing well i was saying
like i think being closeted probably
like attracted me to like versions of
secret sex like i like public like like
stairwells
right right cars you know like like i'm
really into that's your life yeah yeah
yeah yeah definitely getting blown to my
dad's ford explorer right in other words
porn that
deals with keeping it a secret yeah like
you're doing something taboo yeah yeah
yeah yeah like yeah fringe porn
yeah i i i'm really into it it's very
friendly i follow nothing but on my
little ghost twitter i follow nothing
but porn stars
do you oh it's the best it's the best
who's your man i mean who is uh who are
you fantasizing bro i mean it changes
this is i think he's like part latinos
in ohio his kid evan knox so he's really
really hot we like him this is black
dude
xavier
uh like man yeah jesus i wish i i i
should have been more prepared for this
moment because like i really want to
shout i want to [ __ ] some of them
right
well you're famous
so yeah so it's probably going to happen
but i don't have twitter and instagram
so like i like all i have is this moment
how and i'm dr like please have me back
so i can have a list
i will have you back i would like to
have a list of porn stars come in with a
list of people now you even
said that you you would watch straight
porn to try to
when you were a kid and you were so
angry with yourself for being gay you
said watch gay porn and then i after i
was done with that i'd go and watch
straight porn i use
and this is the place to talk very
truthfully about
what how silly is this psychologically i
i would
like as a teenager like jerk off the gay
porn feel the wrath of god's judgment
and then go jerk off to straight porn as
if it cleansed it as if that was the
lamb's blood to wash away the gay scent
silly it's silly what it does shame is
crazy well first of all i applaud your
libido because the fact that you could
jerk off immediately after jerking off
the gay porn and then you're gonna
forget this rape they don't call me no
refractory rod for nothing howard
was it horrible to have to make love to
women um
[Music]
in other words is [ __ ] disgusting
no no no no no no and and i'm i'm really
good at eating [ __ ] and it's a shame
that i i just what a wish yeah just a
skill that's just yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm like i'm like bill withers i retired
early and i just went back to georgia